vamos a dibujar un triángulo ok vamos a
empezar digamos con este lado que mide 6
por ejemplo digamos que este lado rosa
de aquí puede medir 10 y vamos a decir
que este último que estoy pintando de
verde mide x lo que voy a pensar es qué
tan grande o pequeño puede ser x ok qué
tan grande o pequeño puede ser esta es
la longitud del lado verde la primera
pregunta es qué tan pequeño puede ser
entonces si si hacemos esto simplemente
vamos a mirar a este ángulo este ángulo
que está comprendido entre el lado azul
y el morado y vamos a tratar de hacer
ese ángulo tan pequeño como sea posible
entonces por ejemplo si tenemos nuestro
lado de longitud 10 voy a hacer esto muy
muy pequeño que se va aproximando a 0
déjenme hacerlo acá ok entonces aquí
está el que mide 10 y luego tenemos el
ángulo que vamos a aproximar lo
realmente a cero para de generar el
triángulo ok
así que esencialmente se convierten no
en una figura dos dimensional sino en
una línea pero a medida que aproximamos
a cero
este es el lado azul prácticamente se
está encima dando sobre el morado y
puedes imaginar también cuando coinciden
verdad y tenemos un caso degenerado
cuando el punto donde termina el azul se
encima sobre el lado morado porque ya
estamos minimizando así la distancia de
x
es eso todo resulta de minimizar el
ángulo déjenme dibujar una progresión
por ejemplo ahí tenemos un ángulo muy
pequeño y por lo tanto nuestro x se hace
cada vez más chico y que mantenemos
haciendo este ángulo más y más pequeño
hasta tener un triángulo degenerado
déjenme ponerlo así entonces este mide
10 así que el ángulo ya es 0 así que
tenemos nuestro lado encima do el azul
de longitud 6 así que cuál es la
distancia entre estos dos puntos bueno
la distancia es equis pero en este caso
degenerado es este segmento x ok y
sabemos que 6 más x debe ser igual a 10
porque encima mos los segmentos verdad
así que en este caso de generado x es
igual a 4 así que si queremos que esto
sea realmente un triángulo no podemos
hacerlo igual a 4 así que al menos debe
ser más bien debe ser un número
estrictamente mayor que 4
ok ahora pensemos en la otra forma qué
tan largo puede ser x bueno si pensamos
acerca de qué tan grande puede ser x
ahora pensemos en el ángulo que lo
estamos haciendo cada vez más grande así
que vamos a hacer esto vamos a dibujar
el lado de longitud 10 que es el rosa ok
y vamos a ir haciendo el ángulo cada vez
más grande este ángulo de entre el lado
morado y el rosa así que a medida que
nos aproximamos a 180 grados otra vez
nuestro triángulo se va a convertir en
un segmento se va a degenerar ok y
déjenme dibujar la longitud de aquí x
así que vamos a tratar de maximizar esta
distancia entre los puntos finales de
los segmentos y vamos directamente al
caso de generado entonces cuando tenemos
180 grados ahí tenemos nuestro segmento
azul que coincide con el segmento rosa y
se hace un segmento mucho más grande así
que en esta situación cuál es la
distancia entre estos dos puntos bueno
tenemos
esta distancia es equis pero en esta
situación tenemos que mide 6 + 10 que es
igual a 16 así que si tenemos el caso
del triángulo degenerado entonces mide
16 pero no queremos s así que
necesitamos que sea menor que 16
ahora todo este principio en el que
estamos trabajando aquí se llama el
teorema de la desigualdad del triángulo
y es una idea muy básica así que de
cualquier lado de un triángulo tiene que
ser menor que la suma de los otros dos
lados así que la distancia
lado
tiene que ser menor que la suma de las
distancias ok de los otros dos lados ok
de los otros dos lados si estamos
trabajando con triángulos degenerados
bueno podríamos permitirle que fueran
iguales verdad aunque estamos hablando
de una figura unidimensional que es un
segmento y no nos gusta eso a final de
cuentas así que vamos a poner que la
longitud de un lado debe ser menor que
la longitud de los otros dos de la suma
de los otros dos de este principio nos
sirve para resolver esta misma pregunta
por ejemplo x debe ser menor que la suma
de los otros dos que son 66 + 6 + 10
o bien en otras palabras que x tiene que
ser menor que 16 ok
es el mismo resultado que obtuvimos
visualizando lo de esta forma ahora que
tan pequeño puede ser x bueno notemos
que 10 debe ser menor 10 debe ser menor
que la suma de los otros 2 verdad y la
suma de los otros dos es 6x entonces
tenemos 6 más x ok es la suma de los
otros dos lados si restamos 6 de ambos
lados 10 menos 6 nos queda que son 4 y
es menor que x
o que x es más grande que 4 así que
hasta es cierto nivel esta es una idea
muy básica pero hay algo que lo verás
definitivamente siempre que es en las
matemáticas en la geometría y verás
otras versiones de lo que es el teorema
de la desigualdad